All the cells in your body are filled with proteins performing
all kinds of functions that make up the basis for your traits.
>> Okay, but where does the protein originally come from?
>> Right, so we've finally come to the, the whole point of this,
right? It comes from the genetic instructions
inside the cells of your body inside
the nucleus. You have two copies of your genome, one from mom and one
from dad, six billion letters of information
It sounds like a lot of information.
How does it get turned into something else though?
>> Well this is when it's time for us to
think about our genome book again, not like just a book,
but a book of recipes. You've got lots of recipes to
make up who you are. We don't need all of them
right now, we just want to focus on blood type. So I
may have the blood type recipe for type A and you
have the blood type recipe for type B. Maybe a better
way of doing this is to actually go ahead and you
know, get a, get a real recipe out here.
>> Okay.
>> We'll, we'll be pretty udacious about this and I want to give you
this example of a recipe that Lauren,
this was a, a recipe from your grandmother.
>> Okay.
>> Let's start simple with the recipe we
see here. What food is this most likely going
to make? Now, I'm going to read out the
recipe really quick. Our measurements are very American centric.
So we're not using the scientific metric system
here. But we're going to take our first 6 ingredients,
and mix them well. A cup of butter, 4 eggs, a cup of milk. 2 cups of
sugar, 2 and half cups of flour. A
teaspoon of baking powder. And we're going to mix it
all together. And as one of our later
ingredients, we're going to have 1 tube of blue icing.
[UNKNOWN]
We'll pour this into a pan and bake at 375
degrees fahrenheit for 20 minutes, then we'll remove it from
the pan, cool, and then we can add our icing.
So tell me, what food is this likely a recipe for?